bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission que même le kobe 19 n'a pas
pu empêcher
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler du fossé qui se creuse entre
l'économie réelle et la bourse bonjour
estelle bonjour olivier bonjour à tous
bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode de ses
caches quel lien entre la bourse et
l'économie réelle
l'étal de la bourse reflètent ils
exactement la santé de notre économie
ce sont là les questions qui vont nous
occuper dans ce nouveau numéro de ses
caches où l'on va tenter d'analyser le
rapport entre la bourse et à l'économie
réelle et pour cela nous serons en
deuxième partie à des missions avec
philippe béchade rédacteur en chef de la
bourse au quotidien les pouvoirs publics
n'ont eu de cesse de le marteler la
pandémie de copies de 19 à engendrer une
crise économique sans précédent
pourtant les marchés boursiers eux
semblent avoir retrouvé leur niveau
d'avant la crise comment expliquer à ce
décalage éléments de réponse avec le
tiroir cash d'antoine d'assas
[Musique]
y at il réellement un rapport entre
bourse économie réelle vous vous dites
oui évidemment sauf que ce n'est pas
forcément si évident que ça la preuve la
banque des règlements internationaux
mais aussi le régulateur des marchés
financiers européens ou encore le fmi
ont récemment mis en garde sur ce sujet
car si le choc avait été bien présent au
mois de mars au début de la pandémie
les marchés financiers ont depuis fait
un spectaculaire rebond retrouve un
presque au niveau d'avant crise quand
l'économie réelle peine à repartir avec
une pendaison toujours en cours et la
crainte d'une deuxième vague voire d'un
nouveau confinement
l'explication réside essentiellement
dans le rôle des banques centrales qui
ont injecté des milliards et des
milliards pour éviter la catastrophe
du coup sur les marchés on n'a plus
vraiment peur on sait que nos
bienveillante banques centrales seront
toujours là en cas de plongeon pour les
rattraper et réinjecter du cash
certaines entreprises au premier rang
les fameuses gars femmes ont aussi su
tirer leur épingle du jeu grâce à
l'utilisation renforcée du numérique
depuis le confinement encore plus
cynique les licenciements et pertes
d'emplois contribueraient elle aussi à
augmenter la valeur de certaines
entreprises en bourse licenciement égale
diminution des coûts de l'entreprise et
garantir une marge plus importante lors
de la reprise
un calcul selon lequel l'amélioration de
la rentabilité devrait compenser la
demande détruite par les pertes
d'emplois
[Musique]
olivier est ce que cette crise liée au
corps 19 elle a accentué ce décalage
entre l'économie réelle et les marchés
boursiers où est ce que finalement ça
ils ont toujours été déconnecté alors
ils sont déconnectés depuis depuis déjà
un bon moment c'est pas le coc vie qui
les a déconnecté
récemment c c'est depuis que les banques
centrales ont une politique d'impression
monétaire et ses fameux quantitative
easing que finalement elles n'ont arrêté
que très brièvement
depuis 2009 donc on a on a depuis 2009
un afflux de mener sur le sur les
marchés financiers et qui soutiennent et
qui font monter les marchés financiers
là aujourd'hui vous êtes alors
aujourd'hui ça se voit encore plus si
vous voulez mais c'est pas c'est pas un
phénomène nouveau mais ça se voit
tellement parce que on a tellement une
économie qui est par terre
aujourd'hui et une bourse qui elle est
tangente ses plus hauts en tout cas en
ce qui concerne les les américains - les
européens mais on est sur des bourses
qui se porte bien avec des valorisations
qui sont sans arrêt plus élevé alors
qu'on sait très bien que les boîtes en
question et l'économie en général est
très très très très loin derrière mais
si vous vous laissez c'est devenu la
très flagrant mais c'est quelque chose
qui conseille depuis longtemps on sait
que les banques centrales
aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas se permettre
un très fort recul des marchés
d'abord parce que l on des titres donc l
ont pas envie de faire des pertes
monumentales et puis aussi parce que
vous en avez dans les fonds de pension
américains qui permettent de payer les
retraites et que ça ferait désordre si
on payait plus les retraites aux états
unis donc tout ça fait que les banques
centrales sont devenues ce qu'on appelle
marc est dépendante et pas du tout elle
n'est elle ne s'occupe pas finalement de
l'économie réelle
ce qui les intéresse c'est que la bourse
continue de monter parce que on s'est
toujours dit que si la bourse allait
bien finalement ça allait redonner
confiance aux gens mais le problème
c'est que je lis 10 x fois sur sept sur
cette émission ça n'est pas la queue qui
remue le chien c'est le chien qui remue
la queue et vous en savez quelque chose
et stahel puisque vous avez un chien
merci aux visions pas si tu as la
deuxième partie de cette émission et
cette semaine pour parler du lien entre
la bourse et l'économie réelle nous
sommes en liaison avec philippe béchade
rédacteur en chef de la bourse au
quotidien bonjour monsieur béchade vous
emmener dans ses cages
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors une réaction
pour commencer à cette phrase de paul
krugman lauréat du prix de la banque de
suède en sciences économiques le marché
boursier n'est pas l'économie est ce que
c'est votre avis aussi
ça n'a jamais été aussi vrai rien à
ajouter à ça et si j'écoute le
développement fait par olivier j'y
ajoute le fait que la déconnexion entre
le marché et l'économie réelle n'a
jamais été aussi radicale je pense que
les niveaux de valorisation actuels sont
tellement stratosphérique qu'on ne peut
pas qu'on ne peut pas établir le moindre
lien avec les profits attendus à court à
moyen et même à long terme
olivier trop tôt pour parler de cette
déconnexion vous évoquiez l'année 2009
ça veut dire qu'avant il était un peu
plus connectés qu'aujourd'hui non enfin
en fait ça a commencé
ça a commencé réellement
dans les années quatre-vingt dix-huit
2000 où vous avez eu les premières les
premiers afflux de liquidités et ce qui
a d'ailleurs fait la première bulle la
bulle de la bulle internet
mais autant si vous voulez sur la bulle
internet
on savait que quelques entreprises
allaient sortir et donc il y avait
beaucoup d'espoir dans les cours de
bourse
mais c'était à un espoir j'irai positif
où on à survaloriser beaucoup
d'entreprises mais il n'empêche que
quelques monstres ont fait leur
apparition à ce moment là et qui depuis
sa pelle dé google b et c est donc vous
êtes là la revanche aucun espoir à avoir
c'est à dire que vous ne pouvez pas
aujourd'hui la bulle actuelle elle est
très différente
la bulle actuelle elle est purement
mécanique c'est à dire qu'il ya pas de
n'y a pas d'espoir de voir sortir de la
situation actuelle des des leaders ddd
nouvelle gaffe à excédents là c'est pas
du tout cas c'est un gect de la monnaie
qui va directement comme comme de
l'essence si vous voulez dans un moteur
qui va directement dans le marché
financier
ça n'a absolument rien à voir avec
l'économie réelle parce qu'il n'ya pas
un neuro ou 1 dollar de ceux de cette
manne financière qui arrive dans
l'économie réelle
effectivement et donc ça n'est que
diriger vers les marchés alors si vous
voulez le le au départ s'il faut quand
même se souvenir de ce que c'était qu'un
marché un marché financier ça servait à
s'échanger des titres et ça servait
surtout à faire un prix et à donner une
information là aujourd'hui c'est plus du
tout ça ça n'a rien à voir c'est un
espèce de grand casino dans lequel en
plus vous savez que il vous suffit de
tendre la main pour que la banque
centrale vous donne des sous pour que
vous puissiez continuer à jouer donc ça
ne s'arrête jamais et donc vous avez
quelque chose qui il essaie en tout cas
de rendre ce mouvement perpétuel
malheureusement il y a des conséquences
à sac
on va probablement dans les mois à venir
constater injustement si les béchade
on observe donc un dynamisme sur les
marchés quand totale contradiction avec
ce qui se passe dans l'économie
est ce que c'est un problème
concrètement cette déconnexion qu'est ce
qu'on risque d'avoir des marchés
boursiers aussi déconnectée de
l'économie réelle alors le on est
tellement un défi qu'il faudrait quand
même rentrer un petit peu dans le détail
aujourd'hui 1 % des américains les plus
riches
on détient 54 % de la totalité des
actifs 2 % des américains les plus
riches détiennent 75% des actifs et 5%
d'américains les plus riches détiennent
plus de 80% des actifs
autrement dit la hausse des actifs elle
enrichit surtout le top five n'enrichit
pas l'américain moyen
alors qu'on ne cesse évidemment de
justifier le soutien au marché par
l'effet richesse que cela génère je
rappelle que les 50 % d'américains les
plus pauvres ne détiennent que 2% des
actifs en circulation autrement dit là
la hausse des marchés n'enrichit que
ceux dont l'essentiel du patrimoine et
de la fortune et placés en actions
donc si jamais les cours s'effondrent ça
va surtout appauvrir les plus riches ça
ne fera pas grand chose aux plus pauvres
ensuite si les marchés chutent ça
pourrait créer effectivement un choc
alors cette fois-ci de défiance oui
probablement
mais ça fait quand même très très
longtemps que l'on a cessé de croire que
la valorisation des actifs boursiers
constituait une juste anticipations
et profits futurs vous prenez par
exemple apple qui fait des profits en
l'espace d'un an le titre se paye est 10
fois son chiffre d'affaires
aujourd'hui c'est va x soum ses 250 fois
je pourrais multiplier comme ça les
exemples d'entreprises dont la
valorisation ne sera jamais justifiée
par les profits futurs et les l'image
d'olivier tout à fait juste le casino je
voudrais illustré ça de façon très
concrète quand vous rentrez dans un
casino vous échangez votre bon argent
contre des jetons pour ensuite aller à
la table de blackjack ou éventuellement
si vous avez réservé un petit salon vous
avez une partie de poker privée et vous
allez que vos jetons et vous misez
effectivement en fonction de ce que vous
avez en main si vous avez dans la salle
avec vos jetons et que le dire que le
patron du casino vous dites tenait pour
un jeton amené je vous en offre deux ou
trois ou cinq ou dix autrement dit quand
vous avez commencé à miser non lieu de
miser je ne sais pas 100 $ / eu une
perte de 10 vous allez me et 1000
dollars et si vous avez un as en main
vous savez pas mettre directement 500 $
vous allez m 5000 et si en cours de
partie on vous ramène encore des jetons
vous à l'elysée n'ont plus 5000 mais mes
dix mille et ça n'a évidemment aucun
rapport avec la la la la valeur de votre
main à l'origine c'est simplement que
vous pouvez miser beaucoup plus là
dessus
et le problème c'est que l'argent ne
ressort jamais du casino sarkozettes que
je riche virtuellement
merci à philippe béchade messieurs ont
marqué une courte pause et on revient
dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au programme de ce numéro à le
décalage entre la bourse et l'économie
réelle et on en parle avec philippe
béchade rédacteur en chef de la bourse
au quotidien olivier juste avant à la
coupure poudre du pardon monsieur bechet
évoqué un risque d'une remise à plat
complète de l'économie tout entière
c'est votre avis aussi c'est ça le
risque
à bas le risque c'est ça c'est que à un
moment se fait comme dans les dessins
animés on se réveille et s'aperçoit
qu'on est au dessus du vide à ce
moment-là on descend mais on descend de
façon plus qu'important aujourd'hui ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre vous savez il
ya eu beaucoup de depuis le début de la
crise il ya eu beaucoup de comparaison
on essaie de comparer ça avec les années
enfin la crise de 29 on essaie de
comparer sa ex tard et
malheureusement je pense que ça va être
bien pire que ça pourquoi ça va être
bien pire que ça parce que aujourd'hui
vous avez cet excès de monnaies comme il
y en a jamais eu dans l'histoire cet
excès de monnaies et qui tourne beaucoup
plus vite
aujourd'hui pour passer d'un pays à
l'autre pour passer d'un titre à l'autre
extra c'est c'est de l'ordre de la
nanoseconde c'est plus du tout ce qu'on
faisait en 29 ou
vous aviez des corbeilles où vous
traitiez réellement les titres là ça n'a
plus rien à voir là aujourd'hui vous
appuyer sur un bouton et votre argent il
fait quatre fois le tour du monde
le temps que vous buviez votre café donc
c'est c'est pas du tout la même chose
et là vous risquez d'avoir avec toutes
les les les en plus les dérivés qu'il ya
sur les titres et c'est ça qui est
important c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
vous n'avez pas simplement les titres
quand une quand une valeur à un certain
nombre d'actions ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que vous avez 100 fois ça en
termes de dérivés et que donc le jour où
vous avez un vrai pépin est bien là là
là là tous et tous ces produits dérivés
qu'on a fait sur les sur les actions
vont détruire complètement le le cours
c'est à dire que vous allez vous avez
des risques de vous retrouver avec des
valeurs qui vont plonger de 50 60 70 %
dans la journée alors évidemment on fera
tout pour essayer de freiner et croyez
bien que à ce moment là ils fermeront
pour que tout le monde se calme mais ça
n'empêchera pas que allah allah à la
réouverture vous ayez vraiment une
remise à zéro
vous avez aujourd'hui des titres dont on
a vu par exemple nicolas nicolas c'était
où ça s était la tesla des camions s'ils
voulaient qui avait pas de moteur et qui
donc faisait sa pub en tractant un
camion avec un câble et est donc c'est
une pure escroquerie
mais c'est une pure escroquerie qui tend
même aujourd'hui vaut quelques milliards
en bourse
donc on peut se dire qu'il ya un moment
où on va quand même retomber sur nos
pieds parce que parce que vous pouvez
pas payer quelques milles ya un truc qui
vaut rien ça vaut 000 bons simplement
vous avez general motors qui est rentré
dedans donc ils n'ont pas envie de
mettre ça dans leur bilan à zéro donc on
maintient encore un peu les cours mais
ça quand vous allez réellement
prendre conscience peu les choses ne
vont pas si bien en économie et que vous
allez avoir une remise
je dirais pas à zéro mais une remise à
la valeur et non plus aux prix est bien
à ce moment là vous avez des titres
comme ça qui sont des zombies équivalent
0 franchement 0 par pas 10 milliards pas
5 milliards mais zéro messieurs avait
fait pour revenir sur les causes de
cette déconnexion entre les marchés
boursiers et l'économie réelle
olivier évoque le comportement des
banques centrales est ce que on peut
aussi imputé ce décalage à d'autres
choses
c'est réellement que le comportement des
banques centrales il ya d'un côté le
carburant que que l'on met dans la
machine
donc là c'est filmé en grèce sur sa
dette et des banques centrales ensuite
il ya ce que l'on fait quand on est au
volant
il ya le levier de vitesse il ya le
volant qui permet de choisir une
direction de négocier les virages
en fait les gérants sont formatés par
les gérants ou les opérateurs de marché
sont formatés pour utiliser l'argent
dont ils disposent ils ne sont plus là
pour évaluer les perspectives d'une
entreprise la matérialité de ses brevets
de nicolas mais il y en a beaucoup
d'autres
on n'est pas là non plus pour pour
comprendre comment fonctionne le
management comme on l'a vu avec wirecard
puisque là on nous a inventé du chiffre
d'affaires qui n'existaient pas et
personne personne ne l'a vu donc les les
gérants sont simplement là comme des
joueurs de catinot pour affecter le cash
dont il dispose
on leur donne le choix entre en mettre
un petit peu au blackjack un petit peu à
la roulette et ils dispatch l'argent et
les actions
ou n'importe quel actif dont ils ont la
charge
c'est en fait un objet mathématique
ces objets mathématiques
évidemment il ya longtemps qu'on ne
passe plus d'ordre et qu'on ne s'échange
plus des paquets de titres avec d'un
regard ou en se passant un coup de
téléphone
ce sont des algorithmes qui
effectivement vont acheter et revendre
en quelques nanosecondes pas toujours
sur la même plateforme des fois ça
achètent sur les plates formes à et ça
rend sa revanche sur une plate forme b
donc en fait le gérant d'un fonds voit
dire un fonds indiciel ne sait
absolument pas s'il est actionnaire de
telle ou telle valeur at-elle hauteur
c'est pas un choix ce sont des
algorithmes qui vont allouer l'argent
qu'ils vont travailler sur des petites
différences de coût entre entre deux
plateformes
je le répète les actions ne sont plus le
reflet d'une activité humaine
ce sont de purs objets mathématiques
voilà et qui présentent des profils de
volatilité de dynamique haussière alors
on parle de delta de gama de teta et on
est tellement déconnecté du titre réel
d'ailleurs qu'il ya certaines séances où
c'est absolument incroyable et je
demande à ceux qui nous regardent de me
croire vous prenez un titre qui sert de
support à des options il ya un certain
jour il se traite plus d'options que le
titre sous jacent vous vous dites
comment est ce possible puisqu'on est
censé pouvoir arbitrer en permanence
l'option et le et le cash et en plus de
ça quand vous achetez une option vous
achetez sans titre parce qu'on est ce
qu'on se figurent que certains jours il
y a plus des changes sur l'option qui
représente 100 titres que sur le titre
lui-même et pour comprendre où on en est
au niveau des encours de dérivés il ya
dix ans juste avant la crise les mâles
on approchait le million de milliards de
dollars d'encours sur les dérivés le
chiffre était tellement vertigineux ne
savait plus exactement s'il fallait
mettre 23 au 24 0 c'était complètement
dingue et donc au début de l'automne
quand on a pulvérisé de nouveaux records
sur le nasdaq sur le nasdaq on s'est
aperçu qu'on était à 1,2 million de
milliards d'encours sur les dérivés
alors je pour qu'on se figure ce que ça
représente
cela représente 12 ou 13 fois le pib de
la planète ce qui s'échange comme argent
réel
voilà donc je le répète les actifs ne
sont plus le reflet d'une réalité
économique de gens qui travaillent de
gens qui réfléchissent de gens qui font
des brevets le cours de bourse est le
reflet d'une succession d'informations
entre guillemets et la principale
information que traite les algorithmes
ce n'est pas ce qui se passe dans la vie
réelle c'est le cours de la nano seconde
d'avant plus de la nano seconde d'avant
et c'est la preuve après la principale
information dans le prix d'une action
aujourd'hui c'est son prix et la façon
dont ce prix a évalué à évoluer au cours
du dernier dixième de seconde de la
dernière seconde de la dernière minute
et éventuellement sur les très très long
terme au cours de la dernière heure et
ce sera le mois de la fin merci beaucoup
à philippe béchade avoir été à parmi
nous dans cette émission je rappelle que
vous êtes rédacteur en chef de la bourse
au quotidien olivier ont continué avec
les questions cash
olivier comme chaque semaine vous
répondez aux questions des internautes
voici celles sélectionnées pour ce
numéro celle de ryad l'euro était une
monnaie stable ou risque-t-elle une
dévalorisation à moyen terme c'est déjà
fait par exemple sur un actif stable qui
est l'or vous regardez le comportement
du dollar et le comportement de l'euro
elle se dévalorise sans cesse donc c'est
pas là c'est pas une question de deux
monnaies stable ou pas stable toutes les
monnaies papier toutes les monnaies
qu'on a aujourd'hui se dévalorise et se
dévalorise d'ailleurs par le fait que
les banques centrales en imprime comme
on en a jamais imprimé 1 alors
évidemment quand je dis imprimés c'est
pas les rotatives qui tourne c'est c'est
l'image et mais elle crée de la monnaie
si vous voulez et donc quand vous créer
de la monnaie qui n'est adossé à rien
c'est à dire à dhuisy la de la bête
et bien malheureusement votre monnaie
vous ne pouvez pas vous attendre à ce qu
elles montrent ce qu'elles grimpent en
valeur donc aujourd'hui on a des
monnaies qui fondent gentiment au cours
au cours du temps l'euro en est une
et en plus l'euro à un problème mais qui
est spécifique à l'euro c'est que vous
avez en dans une monnaie qui est une
monnaie dans lequel vous n'avez ça ne
vous a pas échappé vous avez plusieurs
pays et ça n'a jamais fonctionné c'est
une monnaie qui a été mal monté donc
c'est une monnaie qui est très faible
le dollar en revanche c'est quand même
malgré tout la monnaie mondiale
alors on peut ne pas l'aimer on peut
dire qu'ils font la même chose
c'est-à-dire qu'ils en créent beaucoup
et c'est vrai dire on peut aussi dire
qu'il ya beaucoup de pays qui essaie de
s'en passer et c'est vrai aussi
ça n'empêche que c'est quand même
l'actif le plus liquide au monde et que
quand il ya un problème curieusement
tout le monde va se réfugier sur le
dollar
on passe à la deuxième question celle de
thierry gall la question demeure
pourquoi les grosses boîtes sous
perfusion type air france ne taille tels
pas dans leur patrimoine colossaux
pourquoi elles taillent pas dans leur
patrimoine colossaux d'abord parce que
elles ont aussi des dettes colossales
alors elle pourrait les rembourser vous
me direz en taillant dans le dans le
patrimoine mais c'est souvent du
patrimoine qui leur leur permet de
travailler donc c'est un peu difficile
de le vendre
et puis secundo ça ne règle pas le
problème quand vous avez une société qui
structurellement ne gagne pas d'argent
parce que son modèle ne gagne pas
d'argent vous pouvez vendre les bijoux
de famille ça va vous permettre de tenir
un an de plus mais ça n'empêche que ça
réglera pas le problème
donc je suis pas certain regardez
d'ailleurs à l'échelle d'un pays ce qui
s'est passé avec la grèce la grèce était
sans fin avec un écroulement de son pib
avec une dette qui était colossal etc
qu'est ce qui s'est passé on a vendu les
actifs le port du pirée les aéroports
etc ont été vendus à des chinois des
européens à des allemands notamment etc
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé est ce que
ça a aidé la grèce à repartir non bien
sûr que non parce que le le modèle en
lui même ne fonctionne pas et bien vous
pouvez vendre alors en plus si vous
vendez des choses qui vous rapporte un
petit peu d'argent
c'est quand même ballot de le filer à
quelqu'un d'autre et
et je vous dis le trou est tellement
colossal de toute façon c'est tellement
le tonneau des danaïdes que ce que vous
allez verser ponctuellement en ayant
vendu les bijoux de famille ne va pas
vous permettre de réussir à repartir
merci olivier c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de votre fidélité sachez
que vous pouvez adresser toutes vos
questions à olivier delamarche sur les
réseaux sociaux ou en commentaire des
vidéos si vous souhaitez revoir cette
émission rendez vous sur notre site
internet à l'adresse rt france point tv
olivier on se quitte avec votre dernier
mot et bien aujourd'hui tous les jours
on vous prouve que les arbres montent
jusqu'au ciel contrairement à ce qu'on
pouvait penser